si está dividido en 95 departamentos
cada uno con su propia asamblea
departamental a pesar de cumplir una
función importante muchos votantes
franceses no tienen ni idea de lo que
hacen la respuesta no es fácil
no lo sé me imagino que todo esto está
perfectamente escrito en alguna parte
elegidos cada seis años las asambleas
departamentales tienen varios roles y
responsabilidades importantes están a
cargo de las escuelas intermedias el
mantenimiento de las vías las
bibliotecas y museos y el departamento
de bomberos también cumplen una función
social clave proporcionando subsidios a
las ong y están a cargo de varios
programas de ayuda financiera y vivienda
más conocidas por los votantes las
asambleas regionales de francia
funcionan de la misma manera pero a
nivel regional sus responsabilidades
incluyen el desarrollo económico
regional
por ejemplo proporcionando ayuda
financiera y subsidios para las empresas
el transporte el establecimiento de
estrategias territoriales y
medioambientales y supervisar las
escuelas secundarias y la formación
profesional a pesar de su importancia
los votantes franceses tienden a pasar
por alto las elecciones regionales y
departamentales en 2015 ambas encuestas
registraron tasas de participación de
alrededor del 50%